for 400 million years sharks and other
fish have been living in our oceans us
humans have been around for just about
three hundred thousand
plastic came along only very recently
but if we were to continue to pollute
the oceans at the current pace it will
take less than 30 years before there is
more plastic in the waters than there is
fish
to put this into perspective imagine
sharks have been on this planet for only
one full year just within the last 15
seconds before midnight on december 31st
we would have already managed to pollute
their entire natural habitat to sharks
this is a tragedy a tragedy of the
commons
[Music]
the tragedy of the commons is a
situation in which individuals acting in
their own self-interest behave contrary
to the common good of all others by
depleting or spoiling the shared
resource through their collective action
the theory originated in an essay
written in 1833 by the british economist
william forster lloyd lloyd argued that
if a herder led a large herd of cattle
onto a plot of common land to graze also
known as commons overgrazing could
happen
for each additional cow the owner of
that cow could receive additional
benefits while all other herders share
the resulting damage there are three
possible solutions that could help with
this
[Music]
social norms and a common understanding
of what's right and what's wrong is
probably our best bet the swiss alps
region for example has been run by a
collective of farmers for hundreds of
years as it is in the interest of all
the farmers to keep the commons
functioning complex social norms emerged
and over time became traditions
but when people don't share the same
values or new people arrive such social
contracts often fall apart and other
solutions can help
[Music]
privatization turning common property
into a private one can give the owner an
incentive to ensure its sustainability
if that happens it's important that the
party who now owns that common or rights
of access pays the full price for its
exploitation privatization works well
for things that can be fenced off such
as land but less so for water or air
if someone creates negative
externalities on private land but
doesn't pay the full price of such
externality we need to turn to the third
solution
[Music]
state regulations such as farming
permits can limit the amount of commons
available to everyone and thereby
protect them
fishing quotas can ensure that those
that take also pay the bill
taxes can create financial incentives by
increasing the costs for creating
negative externalities such as polluting
the air regulation can make exploitation
not only more costly tax incomes can
also be used to invest in initiatives
that help reverse the damage done
[Music]
for complex problems such as the plastic
in our oceans we probably need a
combination of all three we can help
create awareness so we all feel morally
obliged to reduce our personal use of
non-recyclable plastics we can ask large
producers of single-use plastics to take
full responsibility for the mess their
products create by dedicating resources
to help clean up countries could commit
to local and international agreements
that regulate the production of
single-use plastic and other pollutants
[Music]
the grazing rules which were established
in switzerland in 1517 are still in
force today they state that no one is
permitted to send more cows to the alps
than he can feed in winter applying the
same rules to plastics would mean no
state ought to produce more plastic than
they can recycle within the confines of
their own borders what do you think
would a similar solution work for the
oceans and if not what else can we do to
protect the commons from the tragedy
that's unfolding share your thoughts in
the comments below
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts